the time is upon us we're about five
minutes behind schedule actually so I do
want to get this rolling thank you so
much for coming out on a Wednesday
evening for what is bound to be I think
a really good discourse we have two very
established and interesting mayors and
we have a very established an
interesting moderator and we have some
other great people who hopefully are
going to be giving good questions and
that's you and as such look on your
tables it says how to do it we're using
an app log on to the app just using any
browser and you could enter any question
you want it's gonna come to a iPad and
then the questions will be check marked
and sent to Lori who will then ask them
this will happen towards the end of the
one hour session okay and for those of
you have not been here yet today my name
is J Whittaker I'm the director of the
Scott Institute for energy innovation I
welcome you to campus if you are new
here thank you for coming and it's my
job to introduce the moderator for
tonight an interim program interim
provost lori greiner
dr. Wyner does Carnegie Mellon's interim
provost and the Richard M and Margaret s
hired professor of organizational
behavioral and theory in The Temper
School of Business
she's a nationally and internationally
recognized scholar on group processes
conflict management and negotiation dr.
Wyner has been a member of the CMU
faculty since 1989 and previously served
as senior associate dean for education
at the Tempur school as interim provost
at carnegie mellon she is responsible
for leading CMU schools colleges
institutes and campuses and is
instrumental and institutional and
academic planning and implementation so
without further ado we welcome Lori and
we will continue with the night thank
you
[Applause]
good evening on behalf of our president
Farnum Jahan Ian and this Carnegie
Mellon community I'd like to welcome you
to a very special energy Week panel
discussion to get us started and I'd
like to bring to the stage someone who
knows a thing or two about challenges
facing urban areas in the United States
Allegheny County Executive rich
Fitzgerald Thank You Provost Thank You
Lori appreciate that and it is great to
see so many people here this evening
with such an interest in energy
I was we're entertaining an airline
because we're trying to get some folks
to get back and forth to the Silicon
Valley and I was with Dean Garrett at
the pirate game and I will say there are
more people in this room than there are
PNC Park tonight so and a little bit
warmer I think - so pretty good boy we
have two great great panelists here
tonight that are going to speak to
mayor's innovative mayor's mayor's to
deal with challenges on a daily basis
who really understand the not just the
constituencies that they serve but the
impacts that energy and infrastructure
and the things that they deal with and
how they how they interact and the other
great thing is they both have Carnegie
Mellon roots
mayor Peduto our mayor in in in in a
city has done you know tremendous
tremendous work the partnership that I
have with the mayor I'm just grateful
for and what he's been able to do for
this region has been just been great for
all of us and certainly for this great
institution and then who everybody knows
on a worldwide stage is the mayor of
Puerto Rico also a CMU grad Carmen you
lean protein Yulin crews the mayor of
San Juan who went to Carnegie Mellon
just a few years ago so we've got two
people that walk these walk this campus
as students and are
now in leadership positions in their
cities and working on you know all the
challenges that big city mayors have to
deal with so let me introduce to the
stage
mayor Peduto and mayor crease
[Applause]
all right so it's often said that the
most difficult job in the United States
governance is being a mayor of a major
American city when you're a big city
mayor rightly or wrongly you're
responsible for everything that goes
wrong and you rarely get credit for all
the things that go right a big city
mayor is expected to be the city's
biggest cheerleader and it's staunchest
defender its toughest critic and its
most miserly accountant and perhaps most
importantly its de facto parent and as
budgets get increasing ly tighter
population shift economies evolve
big city mayors have to first see which
way the wind will blow in order to best
position their city to survive and
hopefully flourish no moment in time has
been as challenging for big-city mayor's
than this moment mayor's are called upon
to incorporate new technologies retain
and redeploy municipal employees and
maintain a viable tax base and they're
expected to do this while competing with
other cities for new business and viable
promotional opportunities so few things
touch all of these areas as thoroughly
as the energy that powers a big city and
the mayor's we have here today have two
valuable and unique takes on the role of
energy and it plays in reinvigorating
reinventing rebuilding and managing big
cities of today in the near and distant
future so I'd like to start a QA and
with an opening question um although
these two cities may seem world apart
worlds apart Pittsburgh and San Juan
share many similar management and
infrastructure concerns so let's just
start by what do you see as your some of
the energy commonalities we might have
across the cities and how we can
leverage these commonalities to continue
to benefit both cities so Peduto thank
you
first it's great to have you back home
and
I hope you do understand that Pittsburgh
stands ready to be a partner with Puerto
Rico in the rebuilding of a great
territory so he spoke earlier about this
Mayor Mitch Landrieu from New Orleans is
recruiting mayor's from across the
United States to basically create a
sister city relationship with the cities
in towns of Puerto Rico and if
Washington won't help the rebuilding we
will and I'm going to be asking all of
you to be a part of that as we work
together with our sister city when I
look at Pittsburgh's challenges what we
have is a lack of a system of systems so
when we look at energy we look at it
very much in siloed ways whether it's
fossil fuels what's happening with our
tech firms and our research institutions
and renewable energies we look at
antiquated old systems that are not had
the proper investment and what will the
future be for them and the opportunities
of creating new systems within the city
but what we haven't done is looked at at
all as one system of systems and there's
something that is very natural and
basically a force of nature in how
systems work together in how you can
build more capacity if you were working
it together we've recently just recently
created a working database for just
contract work that happens in our public
right-of-ways so all the companies know
what each other are doing so we're not
chopping up streets three times in a
year but at the same time that is only
the beginning of what could be a great
opportunity and I think in both cities
is Puerto Rico rebuilds in as Pittsburgh
goes to its next generation of
energy options how do we create that
system of systems well first of all
thank you very much all for having me
here rich was gracious enough not to say
that I came here from 1984 to 1986 I'm
55 years old I know I don't look it but
I am 55 but I'm gonna take just one
minute to first of all think Pittsburgh
because when the lights go off there's
no water and no medication and you have
been neglected and forgotten it is the
heart and the human spirit that rise
above anyone that tries to put you down
and it doesn't matter of your Republican
or if you're a Democrat it matters if
you're human and you have a soul and
Pittsburgh and Puerto Rico I've shared
many things we shared Roberto Clemente
right and in that connection there was a
connection even harder and that lasts
longer which is the connection of people
that know that they will make it if they
work together not only the Hispanic
Chamber of Commerce of Pittsburgh helped
us the city of Pittsburgh helped us but
above all Carnegie Mellon University
rose to the occasion and showed what
Carnegie Mellon is all about is putting
technology to work by making sure that
technology doesn't replay the heart of
people making sure that we can work
together and what the mayor is talking
about in terms of all of the things that
it mayor I was here last time March of
2014 and you can actually see the
transformation a Pittsburgh you can see
it you can feel it and the world is
talking about it why because you have
made sure
with great leadership and great
partnerships that life does not go on
but life is better for other people so
on behalf of the people of Sun one of
the people that were saved lives were
saved because of people in this room
life were saved because Carnegie Mellon
stepped up life were saves because the
mayor did a lot more than what he's
given himself credit for but there's one
person here that I want to distinguish
the monster and it's a little son I get
any god I don't know what she's sitting
there stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
because when others were not doing what
they were supposed to CMU students were
doing what people thought they couldn't
do when others were saying that the
logistics were too big they were finding
the way and that's one thing that in
this common effort that we have put
forward you have no idea what it is to
be without energy have no idea what it
is to spend months and months and months
with not a flicker of light and we don't
want energy to be able to bathe in warm
water or to have air-conditioning we
want it's where children can go to
school we wanted so that our doctors can
operate in the operating rooms without
having to use the light from their cell
phones we want to sort that our
businesses can reboot and come back and
continue to flourish we want to say that
we can build a just and fair economy and
I was saying today is a bad and good day
for the world over the mayor was
mentioning she had the opportunity of
visiting today at a memorial service for
dr. Martin Luther King and the things he
fought for are the things we are
fighting for if you don't have energy
you will never have a fair and
sustainable economic system that
strengthens democracy because this is
what power is about it's about ensuring
that we all have access to things that
can help us transform our way of life
it's about ensuring and it is it is my
opinion as a mayor of a much smaller
city than the city of Pittsburgh that
the government is there to build
transport platforms of transformation
for the citizens to do what they know
they need so one of the commonalities
that we have is that a Spitzberg from a
different perspective is transforming we
unfortunately must use the experiences
of Adama and Maria
to transform and to diversify our energy
system we are addicted to fossil fuel in
writing there are some terms of ensuring
that fossil fuel goes lower and lower
the emissions every year but it doesn't
happen and it doesn't happen basically
because we haven't done the right thing
in making it happen so that's on us and
we have an opportunity now to change it
so anything I can copy from the mayor of
Pittsburgh I will do so with no shame
and one of the things that pittsburgh
has been great at doing is building
those partnerships partnerships between
students between all sorts of wonderful
educational institutions I'm partial to
Carnegie Mellon of course but there's a
lot of brain power in Pittsburgh and it
continues to attract brainpower because
there is no fear in this city to look at
new things to build upon what didn't
work and make sure that others learn
from what has worked so one common point
is where we start from and we start from
a need to have a fair economy to have a
more just system and to ensure that
everyone has access to energy that is
renewable that is clean that provides
jobs and that helps cities to transform
that's a challenge for us because some
people think it takes a lot of money I
think it takes a lot of vision there's a
lot of vision in this room and we can
make it happen I'm sure of that when the
mayor and I met and I'll finish with
this he told me that I don't think he
remembers well in a couple of years
Pittsburgh it's gonna be different well
mayor Pittsburgh is different and it is
different because you have embraced
partnerships as a way of moving forward
and as a way of trying
new things so I'll be on you like white
on rice
so there's many directions we can go
from here one question I want to ask has
to do with balancing the energy needs of
your population with other municipal
concerns such as transportation and
housing communication and the way energy
plays into this so you talk about
networks and collaboration and also this
idea of how you're delivering power to
residents what the needs are and how
they play off with additional many
municipal concerns so it's I think it's
an interesting question both in terms of
how you managing all the different
demands and also how you're rebuilding I
think this goes back to the first
question to what we can learn from each
other and basically be able to share is
you look to build a city or rebuild a
city you have areas where you're going
to have a more concentrated in dense
development think of the 28 acres by PPG
paints arena think of the Strip District
think about the 178 acres in Hazelwood
these are areas of opportunity where
you're going to see a lot of new
development now the question is how do
you power so we can do it the way that
we've done it since the 1800s and have a
power plant that's out here and ship it
in and be able to power it off the grid
or we can look for new opportunities to
create direct energy to be able to
produce the energy in the areas where it
is being used and when we start to look
at that then overlaying it with
transportation options different grids
in these corridors which then can be
electrified being using solar and
finding those connection areas right
into the heart of those developments
providing access for all whether you
have a car or not to be able to then to
access these areas that we're developing
so many times will create areas where
jobs are but we won't provide a good
part of the population adequate access
to those jobs it has to be a component
of it
and the idea that we have within the
city is we build out these corridors in
the city is that we'll be creating
electric avenues avenues that will be
creating energy within the corridor
itself charging cars being able to take
you directly to those places and others
like Lawrenceville in the Strip District
in partnering with locally based
companies and nationally based companies
to diversify portfolios to be able to
create new opportunities in direct
energy that they didn't have before and
then create the industry here so that
they can then export it and start in
other markets as well having that in
having the companies that have been
around a hundred years on top of the
research being done not only on this
campus but the University of Pittsburgh
and then combining it with a government
that's willing to open up the city as
the urban lab to see it happen is
priceless especially when you can create
new systems or adapt old systems and
have all these other opportunities to
create so many different models of
producing energy on a local level that
it would be a portfolio that you could
then market to cities around this
country and around the world that's what
we want to see what we want to see in
Pittsburgh is a new model of 21st
century energy being delivered in the
places where it is being used being used
at the most efficient method possible
where buildings don't need that much
energy because they're producing in
themselves in that technology and that
engineering is being done in Pittsburgh
and then being able to market it not
only is a benefit for the city of
Pittsburgh but for all cities I think
what the main touches on is very
important it's it's the idea of
diversification is the idea when we're
transforming and rebuilding at this
point it's starting to San Juan has
about 98 percent but our electrical grid
is very weak so we have to diversify and
we're looking at putting together micro
grids for different communities not only
for the disenfranchised communities but
every community has a right to have
control over its power and to have a
backup system of micro grids it's
expected it's about an average three
hundred and twenty eight days of 365
days a year that Puerto Rico gets Sun so
we can use solar energy a lot but it's
not only solar energy it's also using
the wind and also around the coastal
areas using the ocean to be able to
generate energies in in the middle of
Puerto Rico there's now called Combe
ideal and as a dam and if it's used to
create energy just using the water it
will provide energy to a very vast
region one of the Ellen insisted before
edom on Maria
all of the energy in Puerto Rico was
produced from the southern part of the
island now after Maria there's a little
portion that's produced in the northern
part of the island not in San Juan very
close by so we have to really divide not
only the entire island of Puerto Rico
but also the cities in in terms of micro
grids so that if one for another it's
not only the Hurricanes it's also
transportation one of the things that we
saw with with the hurricane is that I
can have a generator generators are not
meant to run for seven months 24 hours a
day seven days a week so we're piling up
the island with generators but we must
use the opportunity to look at that
portfolio of options and to look at
other cities that have already started
doing that and just simply ensuring that
we have hope and actually
that's what I call it hope and action
we have a non-governmental organization
called Operation Blessing it's out of
Virginia that has given Solar puffs
solar-powered limbs there are little
cubes you put them out eight hours and
they give eight hours of light and they
light up a normal sized room and one of
the things that then has given people is
the opportunity to note that solar power
truly works because we would turn to
think that well you know it's it's it's
something out there that I cannot use or
I cannot afford so we have to create
three co-op systems through
entrepreneurship through small companies
through community develop companies this
micro grits that can be used not only on
a solar power but another different type
of alternative grits and any decision
that we make now we make in the city of
someone based on how much energy can we
save or what is the energy opportunity
cost and just briefly our stadium which
is the largest and the oldest in the
Caribbean it's called au e Dom B thorn
stadium it was a first ball player to
play in the u.s. major leagues from
Puerto Rico got crushed the lights got
crushed and the insurance gave us 1.1
million dollars but if we put two
hundred thousand dollars from municipal
money we could retrofit everything and
have LED lights so we went from seven
hundred and fifty four lights to 150
sixty seven lights from a consumption
every time we turn the switch of 1.2
million kilowatts to a consumption of
two hundred and twenty-two thousand in a
year we're gonna save 1.2 million
dollars and that's without even looking
at putting solar packs in in the park so
we have to look at anyone here with kids
you saw Lion King 20 times
you know the circle of life well that's
a circle of energy because then we have
to look at transportation and see if we
can make them electric and and then we
have to look at our citizens and see how
we can make it affordable so they can
put solar panels that they can take out
when a hurricane comes and put it right
back in so we have to create that energy
system so that different options are
available to different people to serve
different needs but we also have to do
what Pittsburgh is doing which is
ensuring that those options are very
well and very in a very structured and
thought out manner distributed
throughout the city so that there are no
pockets of development and pockets of
underdeveloped areas because again
that's what energy gives you it gives
you a roadmap for the direction of
transportation of Education and of
opportunities pearl so turning the micro
grid concept back to the city of
Pittsburgh how do you think about micro
grids in terms of serving our
communities what obstacles might be in
the way of implementing those well the
technologies there so I mean it's being
used more and more rapidly in Europe and
in Asia that I think some of the the
challenges that we have one definite
area is we don't want to see an area be
able to take advantage of a district
energy plan and then have a red line
around part of the adjacent area simply
because of market conditions what we
want to be able to do is include
especially the areas where affordability
is a critical issue as a component of
creating affordable housing so adding
that in next to the hospital or the
university that present a greater
economy of scale getting
single-family homes to be able to be a
part of that as well that's one of the
challenges that it's not you you can
easily overcome it looking at how you
put together RFPs and asking for bids to
be able to include it some of the other
challenges is building the capacity
within your city workforce to be able to
understand the industry with people who
have that experience and then keeping
them in city government which pays far
less than what the private sector would
like to take them so you want to be able
to have really smart talented people but
you also want to be able to keep them in
those positions you know it's a it's a
very technical field of energy and
trying to understand the science of it
requires a very specified mindset so
we're blessed in the city of Pittsburgh
we have really good young leaders who
have chosen to go the public route even
though they could choose to go the
private route so that when the private
companies talk to us about ideas that
they have they're able to speak and
communicate in their own language we do
is we want to attract companies to come
down to Puerto Rico and that means come
down to San Juan and we'll make it worth
your while
there are things that mayor's legally
ethically morally can do to ensure that
you and I say that because I know the
mayor is very big on ethics and and
that's a plus because you know in our
line of work there's a deficit of that
so when you get one that looks at ethics
and it's important for them that's very
important but but one of the things that
we can do is is in terms of enticing
companies because right now there's
billions and billions of dollars that
will eventually flow into Puerto Rico
eventually they're not flowing right now
not one cent of the four point nine
billion dollar loan has hit Puerto Rico
at this point on one set and we're 58
days from the next hurricane season with
five hundred thousand homes needing
major reparations major reconstruction
completely in San Juan about 26,000
homes have the blue tarps or the blue
roofs which are still temporary roofs
that send one alone it's five hundred
thousand around Puerto Rico and one of
the things that that we need to do is to
to make sure that people come to Puerto
Rico and use San Juan and even if you
don't want to use someone I can help you
to use other chances to happen when I
say use I mean in the proper legal
ethical and moral sense sense of the
word but I think that that the mayor
touched upon something that it's very
important and it's something that it's
Carnegie Mellon high school students we
we dealt with you know do you take a job
in the private sector do you take a job
in the public sector
I moved from one area to another I was
hired by Westinghouse just headquarters
here just out of a what we call the
school of urban and public affairs supa
at the time and then I went into the
federal government and then I went back
into the private sector and then I went
into there was something you know that
kept drawing me back and and it's
something that it's very important when
you get people you have to retain people
in the public
sector it isn't about the money lord
knows it isn't about the short hours
lord knows it is about how you can
transform people's life and it's about
you can be a platform for getting people
together and being great connectors and
activities like this give that
opportunity to a lot of people so so
when we're building micro grids at least
from the perspective of San Juan we have
to make sure that we build them from a
perspective of equality and justice
mostly for disenfranchised communities
but also as the mayor mentioned not to
create pockets of instability in the
communities that are around it and look
at the elderly population we are the
second city in Puerto Rico with the
largest number of elderly population and
we have to make sure that it's it's
different from an area and urban area or
single homes are the ones that are going
to be using the electricity were
buildings are the ones using the
electricity and who do you attract do
you attract people that will use up in a
month more than 10 companies use up in a
year or do you attract people that are
conscious and that it will be moving
with you all the time to make sure that
this is an equitable and sustainable
system and those are different questions
that that we have to deal with from the
perspective of rebuilding and
transforming and taking the next step so
cities are certainly seeking strategic
management and technological assistance
from academia you have both very close
connections with Carnegie Mellon given
the massive energy challenge that cities
face what can we do to help
what can universities do to be of
greater assistance we had a press
conference this morning with Carnegie
Mellon's Metro lab and we went to them
the foundation community of Pittsburgh
and said help us to become better at
preventing fire here's data about all of
our buildings here's data about the
history of fires in the city of
Pittsburgh and they looked at 22,000
commercial properties in the city of
Pittsburgh and they came back and they
said these 57 present the highest risk
in the past eight months 50 of them have
had to have the fire department come out
over eighty eight percent accuracy
myself the director told the fire chief
my job is to make sure you don't have a
job but that type of predictive
analytics being adapted into a city and
then even in the further look of where
the most dangerous problems for fire
were they were able to predict 33% based
upon the past year of incidents what we
can do is then go to the property owner
make sure their sprinkler systems
working make sure their HVAC system has
dampers so that if smoke comes through
it won't go into every apartment in the
building make sure that they're up to
code and be able to prioritize that so
if a fire does happen there the chance
of fatality is very low now if you can
do that with fire prevention imagine
what you can do with issues such as
metering energy use in providing
on-demand pricing and being able to wash
your laundry on a weekend when energy
use is lower in systems won't be able to
get to breaking points be able to
utilize the data that is being presented
to utility companies and to government
and pull all of that together in order
to see where the shocks and stresses are
the most we could completely create
a more efficient system than we
presently have and be able to build from
it a more efficient effective and
equitable system so I think that's the
the area where academia can help the
market will drive certain innovation the
market will drive profitability the
market will drive in a lot of ways
towards where the shareholders will see
reward this government will push for the
equitable side where it's it's for all
and we'll look at greater energy use and
diverse energy use in order to lessen
carbon footprint in academia can work in
between both in sort of bring those
worlds together in our case you can help
in many different ways one is we need a
blueprint and when you're in a crises
you're in a crises mode you know you're
you're putting out fires all the time
and the day to day really takes over the
short medium and long range process so
if you get seven students and you put
them in the room and you tell them to
think about what are the priorities
energy wise that have to be said in
order to get the more efficient system
that you can get and what are the areas
that you need to attack first do you
need to attack first all of the health
system do you need to attack first all
of a school system and how do you go
about retrofitting every one of those
systems to make sure that they lock
amongst one another and you can come
back from a crises or from a flooding or
from a hurricane because as someone said
we are an island surrounded by water
lots and lots of water ocean water we
didn't know that until he said it but
that's the same guy that was elected to
represent the people of Pittsburgh this
is going to continue to happen and
although some people deny that climate
change is real so we will continue to
see more and more hurricanes and
stronger hurricanes so so we need to set
out a blueprint and this is not only a
summer great project but it's an ongoing
project and we don't know anything about
microgrids I know what I've read in the
journals and so forth and of course a
company can come in and put a micro grid
but what we want to do is smooth power
people we want to make sure that we have
our people trained so that they can
continue to sort of preach if you want
to call it that to ensure that the next
generation which is here now knows that
there's a different way of moving
forward so that's that's one way that
two things that you can do is what
you're doing now is you know connect us
with a lot of people that know a lot of
different ways mayors that are not
afraid to push things forward and look
at best practices so then we have access
to best practices and know you know I
was talking to the Ford Foundation and
they said how can we get in touch with
the mayors and I said how about if I
give you a building and you know all the
energy companies are there in that
building and half a space and you spend
there a month and you do sort of like an
energy fair and mayor's will know what's
out there in from the standpoint of
Puerto Rico when people are dying
literal and this is not a hyperbole and
they have to hang on to a rope to cross
a river because the bridge is gone and I
have to put my child in my back to go to
the other side and make sure that I can
plug my nebulizer to anywhere that has
energy so my kid doesn't die of an
asthma attack I'm concerned with that I
don't have time to think I have to act
or I will die and that kind of a thought
process of structured thought process
put in a room with also people from the
municipalities will provide for a road
map that will challenge what we think
about and make sure that we move things
in the right direction and the mayor and
I have said it often tonight it's about
creating equitable solutions it's about
ensuring everyone no matter where you
are no matter how many property taxes
you pay then you have access to the same
type of clean energy so that we can
continue to strengthen communities in
the Bakken so the resources that are
needed to move forward the rebuilding to
continue the growth require input from
many different sectors many different
people and you both have talked about
collaborations and connections and I'm
wondering as you think about the
networks that you're building and that
you're supporting where are the very
critical connections and where are the
gaps that need to be filled in terms of
making those connections where do we
where should we be focusing and this
question I didn't give to them ahead of
time so yeah no it's just trying to
think about how this it's almost as if
when you come into office as a Mary I
said do you get the book I didn't get
the book yeah wasn't at the desk
Donald care what job you had before
you're not gonna be prepared so this is
just one part of the learning curve you
hear and you learn from different
publications about district energy plans
and microgrids you you meet with experts
that work in the industries in your town
and they explain to you the different
options that are available right now you
you find out what somebody else is doing
and you ask why can't we do that but it
is a learning curve so one of the big
gaps is getting to the place where your
priority becomes practical where you
know what you want to do but you're not
sure how to get there and that's where
you really rely upon three different
groups you rely upon the industry the
folks who are the leaders within the
industry to be able to show you the
different options that are available you
rely upon your staff to be able to do
the additional research that's needed in
the additional networking that's needed
in order to be able to understand the
issue completely in the new one you rely
upon third parties and in Pittsburgh our
third parties are our foundation
community in our institutions our
universities our hospitals our
nonprofits play a critical role in both
the advocacy and the R&D and if you're
willing to trade in open your city up to
be able to make it that urban lab in
order to get that R&D department
established within your government then
you can really get to that pragmatic
point of this is my dream I want to see
happen and this is how we're gonna get
there for us I think it's also an issue
of seducing people it all comes down to
that how do we entice people to come to
Puerto Rico I ruined
businesses to come to sin right how do
we make sure they know that there's a
market there that will not only be good
for them but will be good in opening
markets in Latin America that you become
not only a lap but sort of a window
shopping place so so how do we ensure
that a vision has a result that is
tangible that not only people can see
but that can be used for some smaller
groups of people or in terms of the
number of people that will be having an
advantage to that so so that's one thing
of course for us there is an issue of
money how do you get the capital to
invest how do you plug in to the world
economy and to other advocacy and in San
Juan we make sure that we and you have
to learn from your own mistakes and from
other people's mistakes
we had no power none we used this to
take pictures if we were lucky enough
and maybe for an alarm and FEMA was
telling us to go to the internet to
register for individual assistance there
was no power there was no internet and
one of the most fearful things and the
things that we have to look at is how do
we establish a communication system
which also plugs into that diversity of
energy so that we don't lose it because
if you have you know you you don't know
and it sounds like a joke but if I would
have had one of this messenger pigeons I
have a news for you
satellite phones don't work you really
have to go on top of the building for
the satellite phone to work they didn't
work in Puerto Rico so we have no
connection no connectivity nothing and
energies used to power that what
happened was that all of the towers were
running on generators and they were
started
like fly-ins and then the communication
would come up and would go down so we
need to ensure that this this energy
ecosystem touches upon every area the
area of communication the area of
transportation it would be incredible if
somebody could say and you know give it
to FEMA and say look your map for were
your warehouses to provide MREs used to
be that was 50 years ago it's not
fuel-efficient they would make mayors in
Puerto Rico go 80 miles of diesel fuel
one way and 80 miles of diesel fuel
another day on a daily basis to pick up
provisions any CMU student any CMU sit
on the first semester could plug the
numbers and let FEMA know that that's
not efficient so we need to have that
that that connectivity to ensure that
the lessons learned are not on a
continuum of of things that should have
never happened and how do we learn from
that how do we learn from cities that
that have gone to the next step and and
how do we move forward so the money part
is critical in terms of us but it's also
critical and that's on us what we're
willing what we're looking to put on the
table in terms of being fearless by
looking at new opportunities because
people would say well you know maybe
it's not safe well if others have tried
it I worked in West Mifflin for the
nuclear fuel division for Westerners in
Puerto Rico nuclear fuel it's too small
little place 100 my
long by 35 miles wine but we also have
to be able as a society to change that
chip and to ensure that we're willing to
look at different opportunities which
may be scary yeah those connections seem
incredibly important in bridging those
gaps so certainly that's how I'll move
it forward I want to have some time are
there questions from the floor that have
come in we have a lot of questions okay
great make sure that opportunity so a
question came in I was just in Puerto
Rico and saw the impacts of inconsistent
expensive energy what are the largest
impediment to bringing renewable energy
to the island politics there's there's a
lot of division and not a lot of vision
[Music]
right now the Puerto Rican Power
Authority is up for sale something that
I'm totally against because to me an
essential service is a great equalizer
but it's also the the inability for
people to see what's in it for me in the
immediate sense so right now it's the
time to tell people if you want to
harvest the ring it's a good time if you
want to make sure that you have solar
panels it's a good time we don't produce
solar panels in Puerto Rico we don't
produce one solar panel so anything has
to be important now you know there's a
tariff of 30% anything imported from
China come to Puerto Rico it'll be
cheaper it'll be a lot cheaper and you
don't have to built the entire thing
there you can just finish the assembly
there and bring it into the United
States and it will be cheaper but but it
mostly is that
that people have to see what is the long
run benefit right now two hundred
thousand people like etc without power
most people went without power for about
six months so they wanted the electrical
grid back up that's one thing and the
second thing is the staffer Act FEMA
gives you money to rebuild not your
transform not your retrofit
so you have to do exactly what was there
before which was weakened inefficient
now it'll be tough and inefficient and
and that's why we continue to ask for a
complete waiver of the Stafford act for
energy purposes and the Jones Act -
Jones Act and my heart goes out to our
maritime brothers and sisters increments
everything by thirty to thirty three
percent it was a way for seven days for
airmen and ten days from idea so we're
asking at least for a waiver of the
Jones Act to be able to bring in
products which are lower and which will
help us that diversify and in fact USVI
has a waiver for energy reasons and
they're very close by so those are three
main things that that impact our ability
to do it but I want my electricity now I
don't have time for another
infrastructure to be built so they have
to go at the same time sometimes you
have to build the plane and fix it at
the same time okay I think we have time
for one more question so it's actually a
great question because it's a two-part
question about young people so the first
is with many young people moving out of
Puerto Rico because of the current
situation which affects long-term
economic viability what are the steps
that you can take to help stem that
which is with our population loss a good
sort of commonality question in the
second part of it is how can students
plug in and get involved in energy and
resilience work in Pittsburgh and San
Juan
yeah well the way to get involved is to
basically get involved there's a there
are a lot of opportunities that present
themselves in the city with city
government and with the companies that
are located here if you're looking to
build a career in energy and you want to
be involved in Pittsburgh there's a lot
of other opportunities like this and
getting to know the people in this room
will provide opportunity will provide
young people opportunities throughout
the next four years in looking at
different types of energy options within
the city but you got to get involved
it's not going to come for you you have
to go out and find it it is thought the
numbers aren't there astray that in the
past three years about five hundred
thousand people have left Puerto Rico
300,000 of them have left since November
we couldn't leave Puerto Rico September
or October I'm sure a lot except for the
people that Roxanna was bringing to get
medical attention and other Pittsburgh
Pirates were also great and helped a lot
but
look it's it's an issue of of what do
you want your life to be and and how do
you want to impact your life and the
life of others I've done that from the
private sector and I've done that from
the public sector you describe very well
what the mayor's job is all about but
it's also that I was a member of the
legislature in Puerto Rico as a mayor
you can see things from beginning to end
you can tweak the route and make sure
that it achieves the results that you
set out to achieve two things come out
of Carnegie Mellon which I'm sure come
out of other universities but I can tell
you from personal experience
one is your ability to be analytical to
take a big problem and a humanitarian
crisis has ripple effects it's one after
the other and it's the housing crises
and the energy crisis and and the
resources crisis and the fuel crisis and
it just keeps piling up so you have to
break it in two very different areas and
have groups of people work at it but the
teamwork so one thing that you can do I
don't know if you're still doing at
Heinz school but when I came here we had
students do a semester long project so
one of those semester or two of those
semester long projects one can be for
Pittsburgh one can be percent one and
we'll share it with the rest of the
other municipalities is is how do you
make a municipality and city resilient
you know what is the blueprint for
making a citrus that's one thing and the
second one is and we're going to start
in San one an energy department we're
simply going to call it what it's going
to be an energy opportunity Department
because we're looking for energy
opportunities so we're gonna not gonna
make it any more than what it is
and and I'm gonna have a meeting
tomorrow with the president and spoke
with it the Dean of the Energy
Department here to see how we can have
students from Carnegie Mellon University
they can be undergrads they can be
graduate students have a partnership
with us at the city so that we can move
this things forward and have an
actionable plan that we can work at you
can also donate to an organization which
is going to come out of Carnegie Mellon
University uh get him the guys gonna put
it together and it's an organization
that's gonna say look these are the
problems that communities have what is
it that you can do but I think the most
important thing that the people in this
room can do look if you think you can
help and if you have an idea that you've
used somewhere else
don't nobody wants to be used as a
guinea pig so and that it's worked and
that you really think it can help I'll
be here today tomorrow Friday I'll give
you my personal phone number which is
the only one that I have and and and
let's talk because it is in the shared
common knowledge and the shared
experiences that we can find new ways of
moving forward so don't worry CMU and
the young people we're gonna squeeze
everything out of you well with that I
you know want to follow up on the theme
of collective action and what we can
accomplish together so through the
Carnegie Mellon community the city of
Pittsburgh the city of San Juan together
we're gonna move this forward I think
the Energy Center is at Carnegie Mellon
is at the forefront and we're very proud
of all they're accomplishing and all
we're going to be able to do together on
this front so with that please join me
and
in thinking our two mayor's can I say
one less than you bet the American
people have been an enormous ly generous
with us you may not know it but even if
you retweet something or share something
in facebook
you've helped raise the awareness of
what has happened in a true humanitarian
crisis and and just as a human as a
puerto rican as a mother of a 27 year
old woman born in pittsburgh making
woman's hospital i I want to thank you
for it you have no idea what it is to
know that you're not alone you have no
idea how it feels when you know others
think your life matters you have no idea
what it is to see sparks of light in
complete darkness literal and you have
no idea what it feels not to be
forgotten so to the mayor of Pittsburgh
that didn't forget us to the Pittsburgh
Pirates that didn't forget to the
Hispanic Chamber of Commerce and Ronan
Vedado that didn't forget us to the
University of Carnegie Mellon but didn't
forget it to looks on again he got and
all of the students at Carnegie Mellon
University thank you for letting us know
that we matter and that you care and for
turning on the lights when others and
neglected their responsibilities you let
us know that the human spirit rose high
and people did not die because somebody
knocked at your door and you answered
the call so don't ever
forget us thank you very much
[Music]
this concludes the panel this evening
please enjoy the rest of energy week
thank you
so one note of house